embrionic brain development takes place
from a structure known as neural tube so
week three of embryonic development is
marked by a key event known as
neurulation or neural tube induction
where a flat sheet rolls and curls
inward to form a neural tube the
blueprint of the nervous system this is
how it looks like in day 18 this is how
it looks like in day 21 and at around
day 24 the neural tube start closing so
the folding is kind of complete the
cranial and the cordal neuropore
eventually closes in Day
26 and the cranial neuropore close at
day
28 eventually the neural tube formation
is done this is how it looks like from a
top view you can see the cross-section
view to get a better understanding of
this process how a sheet folds into a
tube and this is the blueprint for the
future brain